ce couple se lève bien avant le soleil
pour travailler en suisse ce matin-là
laura par la première pendant ce temps
alexis réveil leur petite fille d'un an
et demi bonjour mon coeur dur ce matin
la journée commence un peu avant 6
heures pour millas à peine le temps
d'ouvrir les yeux qu'il faut déjà se
préparer tout à la minute
on sait que pourraient travers la maison
d'assistantes maternelles il faut partir
à 6h15 6h20 grand maximum c'est déjà
difficile pour nous les adultes et un
enfant de moins de deux ans c'est
compliqué lui et son époux sont salariés
dans une manufacture horlogère à une
trentaine de kilomètres de leur domicile
matin et soir ils s'organisent pour
faire garder milhas vu qu'on a des
horaires libres qui nous permet
d'arriver de 6h30 à utah en alternant
avec ma femme là je fais le début de
semaine donc j'emmène la petite le matin
richard plus tard le soir
et puis celles qui s'en occupera en fin
de semaine en route direction la maison
d'assistantes maternelles à pontarlier
sur la route du travail à une dizaine de
minutes de chez eux
[Musique]
fiole enfin je pense
c'est vrai que c'est une chance de l'or
la maison d'assistantes maternelles pour
pour nous coupleux de frontaliers se
permet de faire garder la petite 6h30 à
16h30
donc plus de dix heures par jour trois
assistantes maternelles ce relais
jusqu'à 19h30 pour s'occuper d'une
dizaine d'enfants grâce à des horaires
atypiques
les demandes se multiplient
c'était une condition voilà du projet il
fallait avoir une grande amplitude
horaire pour satisfaire le maximum de
parents on doit refuser des enfants
alors après on a des prix inscriptions
garde des listes d'attentes
créé il ya moins de trois ans est la
seule structure de ce type à pontarlier
entre les micro crèches les gardes
d'enfants à domicile et les maisons
d'assistantes maternelles dans le haut
doubs les offres se diversifie et sont
de plus en plus nombreuses